hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slow-mo guys still at it
this is a pinfire gun we used it a while
ago and uh shot a Lego man in the Hat
oh knocked him fly I thought because
this fires a very small two millimeter
round would it be possible to aim this
at the back of a full-size bullet and
set it off so essentially what we're
going to do is try and fire this nine
mil bullet using a two mil bullet from
that we're going to try and hit the
percussion cap of this and initiate the
propellant inside and I think it'd be a
good demonstration of how important the
barrel of a gun is for accelerating the
bullet because without the barrel I
don't think this is going to come out
very fast at all right so I think um it
would be helpful to have a basic
understanding of what's inside a normal
nine mil FMJ there we go okay so I've
done it as gently as I can you can see
inside all that propellant there that's
what initiates and sends the bullet down
the barrel
so all of that
is ignited by that primer on the back of
the case yeah you see this here that's
what's uh the primer is what's
initiating it and see in there that's
where the sort of flash will come
through yeah it's not the sunniest of
days but thankfully this is a very
sensitive camera uh the TMX 7510 hope to
shoot around 80 000 frames a second to
start with how we're gonna how are we
gonna get this shot well I've kind of
put like a remote pulley string option
so I can hide behind the table even
though it's a tiny little two millimeter
gun I don't really know what's going to
happen when we uh yeah I mean I assume
because the bullet's not held down super
well the energy will be split evenly and
it'll be a case goes One Way bullet goes
the other way I should think so yeah
let's let's hide you away okay so I've
got two seconds of recording it's pretty
tight shot um might have to go macro at
some point but uh we'll just
start pretty wide
see what happens all right are you ready
to load I think I am
so tiny so tiny
okay we're loaded okay
nervous I think I'm more nervous that
it's not gonna work you ready yep
here we go
[Applause]
no try again I think this happened last
time where we it took a few shots to uh
yeah some of them just didn't work yeah
all right attempting to fire
just unloading it quick okay here we go
Barry Oh yes
did it work wow so it doesn't even have
without the pressure doesn't even have
enough energy to get the bullet out of
the case oh what is that real I'm blown
away is there there's a little the
bullet did come out a little tiny bit
look it's budged
we budged the Bullet by a millimeter and
it's like on a funny angle you see how
it's on a funny Angle now so it doesn't
have enough beans to come out of the
case I feel like it just popped the
percussion cap and not the propellant it
can't have done well I can't wait to see
what that looks like let's have a look I
want to see what happened that might be
the shortest distance a bullet has ever
been fired I made no noise
like that's crazy lots of learning to be
done here there is
oh here it goes
what
oh and the propellant didn't get ignited
wait
wait what so what's what is this big
thing coming out the plug the percussion
cap yeah it blew back into the gun what
so hang on we can't see the projectile
here I assume it like came back it looks
like it looks like when uh like a space
shuttle is re-entered it's like the heat
shield oh it looks like when one of the
Rockets are coming down and they're
thrusting backwards look you can see the
projectile come out because there's a
little Gap in the fire so that's
basically the the percussion cap is made
of those two parts okay so there's like
a flat Square bit and a rounded bit with
three holes and what happens is you the
cast the percussion cap yeah squishes
the propellant inside and then those
three holes that you can see of that
second part that came out escape and
initiate the propellant inside the
bullet the entire problem here then is
that we wrecked the back of the bullet
correct interesting so we were maybe
hitting it too hard
it didn't ignite the propellant inside
the bullet but how's it shooting out
because what happened is the it's the
only thing that's exploded out of the
bullet is the percussion capex itself
and instead of forcing the gas around
into the bullet like into the cartridge
where it's supposed to go it just sort
of put a little bit of gas in there and
forced all the propellant beans out
but explain this
it's just like a second load I think
it's firing that's that's that's what's
happening because we've lost the
percussion cap because it came off that
means that if there's nothing to propel
against the back of it's fired it out
and now it's just like burning inside
the cartridge case
can you see all the way through yeah you
can see
you can do like
burnt propellant of the sides there all
right got a little bit more light now so
I'm ditching the top and bottom of the
frame there's not really anything
happening there anyway lowering the
resolution and we're now at 300 000
frames a second do you feel like you're
doing surgery
it's like that game where you have to
like operation yeah that's the one
firing oh yeah
a little bit missed I don't know
no idea
I really wonder what happened there so
I'm pretty sure I got the aim right it
looks like it's gonna hit yeah it's like
lined up nicely it's true wow look how
slowly the Hammer's going now that's
leisurely isn't it it is
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening did it work
what
have you ever delay in it what
maybe it was like a misfire somehow oh
God
oh it came low oh it came in two pieces
it broke I wonder if the Barrel's
damaged and it's like shredding them up
guys quite a lot of beans it's got for
such a tiny little thing yeah so many
beans it's destroying the bullet it's
trying to fire that's mental keep at it
yeah I might try the ball rounds again
what do you think
yeah let's try it it's one of those
videos where the slo-mo looks so much
bigger than it actually is looks like a
massive Cannon it does
sorry oh yep got it got it got it
where'd it go oh I smell the smell of
the gunpowder that time bullet
definitely went did you hear the
difference because I couldn't see when I
couldn't I wasn't looking at it with my
eyes so I have no idea what happened I
don't know where the casing went I don't
know where the bullet went
no idea it was very well lined up this
time
boom
foreign
yeah look at all I don't know how I
wonder how much of the propellant got
burnt there I feel like it might have
just been the percussion cap yeah
because all this is just
yeah so but there was a flash inside
like as the bullet leaves the case yeah
it was there is some
because fired back at equal speed yeah
look good so there was a mild bit of
burn which that's what pushed the bullet
out but it didn't continue burning by
the looks of it just kind of went it
gets fired back at equal speed and
straight back where it came from Imagine
just being like this boom
and like loving it back it's like a game
of really small fast tennis yeah so is
that the bullet on the percussion cap
coming back yes so it delivered the
bullet back to the barrel of the gun
yeah it went oh there you go have it
back son I wonder if it was just a small
amount of the propellant burnt but then
as soon as the bullet left the cartridge
there was just no way it was all gonna
continue to burn because it was burning
so slowly yeah do you know what I mean
wow that is such an interesting piece of
footage that all happened in the tiniest
fraction of a second let's time it from
when the hammer landed to when uh the
bullet left
300 frames wow 108. what are we out
there 300 000 frames
that's bust that's like what a
thousandth of a second something like
that it's crazy fast 300 300 000 that's
a thousandth of a second
that's a millisecond a millisecond
I wonder where it's got I wonder if I
can find it all right this is a jump cut
uh This Is Us from the future in the
middle of filming a different video I've
aged that you're six hours older yeah
but we found
the bullet we found one of the nine mil
bullets yeah so let's say pace it out
shall we
so we got one
two
three
four
five
six
and a half paces
and I found the bullet here completely
whole
I'm blemished apart from a little bit of
like gunpowder Gunk on the base so uh
that's how you get a bullet out without
pliers yeah without the rifling
not a mark on it no rifling nothing look
at it that's how you can tell it's the
one that we've
hit with the pin fires it's not got any
rifling in it's not quite far look back
I'm surprised actually
it's pretty damn far yeah for something
that's quite heavy
well let's keep that all right um
all right back to the past I guess
we have a second type of bullet don't we
yeah so we started with the nine mil
here with the percussion cap which is
made of like I said before the cartridge
case and you've got two little separate
bits of metal and the propellant behind
it
this here is a 2-2 round smaller but
the percussive part here it's called a
rim fire which means that it's all
packed into this one rear part which
means there's no separate parts to come
away so if we hit it and cause it to
initiate then it's not going to sort of
blow apart and not cause the bullet to
go so pretty much if you hit it and it
goes that's it so potentially just be
able to fire this one without wrecking
the back of the bullet which means all
of the explosive force will be still
contained in the case yeah so this will
be a faster bullet exit it probably a
faster bullet exit yeah but they'll be
because there's much less propellant
it's a much smaller round there'll be
less beans but more beans
and essentially more beans on the case
going the other way yeah exactly so I'm
definitely gonna be hiding again yeah
yeah okay so here's our 2-2 bullet on
there longer thinner smaller lined up
nicely nicely aligned and as you can see
a little close-up on the back completely
different rear end just like you be a
different rear end just different from
well you had spicy noodles last night so
that's different it's different to mine
yeah
all right yep
wow yes indeed
disappeared I have no idea where that
went absolutely no idea
that was a one take Wonderland
did it fire it or did it just hit it and
not associate it oh wow oh wow look and
once again oh my God it had that much
power it dented the cartridge case I
think it's busted the end of the gun oh
it has wow and it's the bullet
oh
God
see ya that is out of there that's what
compression does now imagine that in a
barrel it's gonna be way more and
because it's all going to go to the
bullet and the cartridge case stays
exactly where it is
and the bullet just shifted didn't it it
did that left a little left it really
left well I think I think we've got all
the footage we need unless we want to
try a lovely uh pretty adventurous
Pro Blends shot
I mean we can try it
with the two two two yeah
a bit too close
yep
got it wow these go don't they yeah
I'm surprised that the gun firing that
much oh it's torn up the foam
how's the lens
seems fine
get some shade on
ready yeah
wow that is it that's the macro there
oh it gets a dent in it and then pull
back out again
wow so it dented it and then undented it
yeah it like went pong Kong like a like
a barrel being compressed and then
expanded again dude this piece so this
is a this is 75 000 because I couldn't
get the uh yeah I don't have the light
to do 300 with this lens because it's an
F14 yeah so it's expanding so much it's
like where can all this gas go well
firstly pop this out yeah because that
was in yeah now we need more room get
that bullet out of there bullets gone
yeah that is so immensely fast yeah I
never saw the uh the dent in the
previous shot we needed the macro to see
that happen that was crazy yeah it's
like we're getting to see what happens
inside a gun without actually being
inside a gun wow that was so cool that
was really cool yeah that was a total
shower idea that I sort of expected that
exactly to happen but the footage still
blew me away to be honest yeah it was
really exciting it was just like what
happens inside a gun except without the
gun around it so you can see all the
little things that are happening inside
of a gun especially on that 2-2 where
you just see it Slam against the back of
the bullet imagine that was the hammer
and that's pretty much exactly what goes
on inside the in in the gun yeah it's
also a really good illustration of uh
how a barrel helps a bullet come out
rather than the cartridge case because
essentially we were just firing
cartridge cases everywhere and the
bullets were kind of going yeah without
any form of compression there's nothing
there's all the energy just goes
everywhere yeah it's not contained wow I
really I'm really happy with that video
yeah me too it was great well hopefully
you liked it too make sure you subscribe
if you like slow-mo you can check out
our second Channel behind the scenes
things and we've got merch oh I'm
wearing some you're wearing some
pretty old one that one well it's still
relevant do we still do that thing
one thing if Dan sees you out and about
wearing some of our merch he has to buy
you a drink that's just how that goes
yeah that's actually really true that's
true and I think you have done it every
time that's happened it's true although
like conventions and things sometimes
doesn't count it doesn't count okay so
you don't think you could be going too
well and be like yeah give me a drink
I'd be broke
yeah all right well let's pop this in
the museum because it's pretty much
wrecked and uh we'll see you next time
goodbye